[Music]
foreign
thanks for taking a look at Google for
your data analytics needs this quick
video will demonstrate what
organizations can achieve when they tap
into Google data analytics Limitless
capabilities across all data workloads
and users
Lisa is a data analyst at symbol direct
a fashion retailer that manages its own
Logistics across multiple Regional
distribution centers the company
recently experienced a spike in Fleet
Management costs due to an increase in
gas consumption and various other
inefficiencies
[Music]
to get to the bottom of this Lisa knows
that she will need to quickly and
securely combine internal data and
external data analyze data across
multiple clouds and most importantly
work with data without experiencing
limits across size scale and format
finally Lisa will need to tap into
machine learning to model future Trends
and present her analysis in a way that
business users can understand and act on
quickly
what's great about Google's data
analytics is that it provides a fully
interoperable and Limitless data
ecosystem that allows Lisa to innovate
and solve problems faster for instance
Google's data analytics comes with free
embedded and real-time business
intelligence capabilities that let Lisa
quickly get an overview of her business
she notices an unusual spike in recent
delivery times and distances which is
resulting in an increase in gas usage
across the fleet let's dig into this a
bit more
bigquery is the serverless analytics
Powerhouse at the core of the Limitless
data analytics and is built with
elasticity flexibility security and
reliability in mind
Lisa can analyze data of any size or
type without a lot of operational
overhead and she doesn't have to worry
about running out of capacity because
the analytics platform scales to meet
her needs
Lisa can query across clouds and within
integrated data sharing she can easily
and securely Access Data from other
teams and organizations without having
to make copies this is bigquery UI on
the left you can see the data sets Lisa
has access to she can start working with
them immediately she doesn't have to set
up a virtual Warehouse pick a size or do
any of the administrative management of
the warehouse
that's because the Google data analytics
scales horizontally and vertically to
the needs of the organization and is
fully managed with free data ingestion
and on-demand consumption-based pricing
Lisa only pays for the queries she runs
speaking of scale whatever your data set
size Google data analytics can handle it
Lisa first starts her investigation with
a data set that contains historical
order data she wants to make sure there
are no significant changes in orders
even though there have been some
outliers recently in delivery times this
table contains over one petabyte of data
a trillion rows of transactions it's a
real world data set scrubbed and
partitioned by day and clustered by
customer for performance joining tables
at scale is no problem for bigquery
let's look at this query average daily
sales joined against the product table a
trillion rows about 10 seconds no manual
cluster resizing no waiting for a
warehouse to be provisioned the order
data looks good so Lisa is going to dig
further into delivery data to see what's
going on in her dashboard Lisa saw a
spike in delivery times and mileage the
query that backs the dashboard Compares
delivery stats over the last hour to the
most recent five-day window delivery
data is ingested in real time through
built-in streaming support Lisa can
process real-time data without having to
set up additional products tools or
infrastructure that's not something
offered with other cloud data warehouses
Google's Limitless data analytics is not
limited to structured data Lisa can
query against unstructured and
semi-structured data across the
analytics platform directly from within
bigquery for example some of the product
delivery data is in Json stored in
Google cloud storage within bigquery
Lisa can explore the data directly she
can even query against it seeing results
in tabular or Json format as well Lisa's
theory is that the delivery time Spike
may be due to inventory issues at
certain distribution centers so next
she's going to look at incoming
wholesale orders even though that data
is managed by another team team it's
fast and easy for Lisa to get access to
what she needs integrated data sharing
functionality means Lisa can get access
to internal data public data sets
commercial data sets from Google
partners and Google exclusive data sets
such as search Trends all in one place
it's a frictionless experience for
analyzing data across Google's open
ecosystem the purchasing team has set up
a private exchange enabling anyone in
the company to access the data via a
read-only linked data set this means
Lisa can access what she needs without
making copies or moving data around
the purchasing team has published
metadata about the data set So Lisa
knows it's the right one and she can add
it to her project to start querying it
now Lisa returns to the SQL workspace
her shared data set has already been
added to our project and is ready to use
right away
this data set has wholesale order data
but she needs to know a little more
about one of these columns and the
source for that is actually on AWS an
external data source is set up here
which lets Lisa use the analytics
platform's integrated cross-cloud
analytics to query data in Amazon S3 all
within the same SQL workspace Lisa can
look up all distribution centers quickly
she doesn't have to copy any data over
in order to query this data set in S3
and she only pays egress on the results
of the query not the full data set this
means full interoperability across
clouds with lower data egress costs than
with other data warehouses this single
pane of glass to manage and analyze data
is great for organizations that use AWS
or Azure for the application stack but
centralize their analytics on Google
Cloud for example application log data
on AWS can easily be queried from within
Google's data analytics and cross-cloud
data transfer makes it simple to copy
over result sets for anomaly detection
or other log analytics Lisa and her team
can also directly ingest data from
teradata or redshift or even event level
data from Google's ads products Google's
data analytics also integrates easily
with ecosystem data integration Partners
like 5tran and Informatica
security is easy to manage across the
Google data analytics with fine-grained
access controls at the table row and
column level and dynamic data masking
Lisa only sees data necessary for her
job for example Lisa doesn't have the
required access to view all user
information symbol direct enforces data
governance through a centralized data
catalog and can ensure data security and
privacy controls these policy tags are
set in the main data catalog and
enforced in bigquery but Lisa can still
access aggregate information about the
number of customers in each City all of
Google data analytics Advanced security
features are offered at no additional
charge for all customers across the
analytics platform
Lisa now has all of her data sources
identified and looks at the inventory
status by distribution center and it's
clear there is a stock issue she contact
the purchasing team with her findings
and they make adjustments to their
ordering schedule but Lisa also doesn't
want the increase in delivery times to
affect customer retention using Google
data analytics integrated machine
learning Lisa can generate Predictive
Analytics using familiar SQL syntax Lisa
creates a churn prediction model that
predicts the set of customers who are
retention risks which the customer
service and marketing teams can use for
outreach and targeted offers all of
these insights are available from
predefined machine learning models
without having to copy data sets over to
a separate exploration tool it's all
right here on the Fly integrated into
the analytics platform and accessible to
any analyst who can write SQL
if Lisa wants to share this model with
her data science team directly she can
do so easily using vertex AI Google's
native AI workbench including
integration into vertex ml Ops framework
she can also use any of Google's
ecosystem partner solutions from c3ai to
data IQ to data robot that way Lisa's
data science colleagues will be able to
use the notebooks they're most familiar
with they can even use Pi spark directly
from within the SQL workspace Google
cloud is committed to meeting users
where they are and making it easy for
teams to get access to the data they
need when they need it using the tools
most familiar to them
speaking of tools people are most
familiar with do your users like
spreadsheets well remember the query
Lisa ran earlier its results that can of
course be visualized in Google's
built-in business intelligence tool or
partner tools like Tableau or power bi
but it can also be explored directly in
Google Sheets in just a few clicks this
is something Lisa's Finance colleagues
are bound to like no other data
analytics can provide such a set of
Limitless capabilities for all data all
workloads and all users we hope you have
enjoyed this quick tour to get started
today without a credit card get access
to the Google bigquery sandbox by
clicking the link below